was a year ago today that we actually
officially decided we were gonna build
cabin land I quit school rebuilt a truck
cabin drove it around cross-country
looking for the perfect spot to build it
and we found this spot and now we're
here is that a dog great what why this
oh my God look at the rocks babe that's
it break through oh I don't know what
scared me it is a tall grave there are
two sides to cabin land there's the
really gorgeous trees and then there's
also the dog graveyard and old camp site
that is on this property dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde this property for two
[Music]
make this doors medieval as possible so
got lots of beautiful functional
functional it is okay so now it's not
open yet so while we're building heaven
land we're gonna be living in an
Airstream at first it's like a silver
Twinkie in the middle of the rainforest
it's gorgeous
I got like five sweatshirts and five
yoga this is it and I'm wearing a much
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's like 30 minutes till it's
getting dark and I think before it gets
dark we should check out all these
creepy ass houses and make sure no one's
squatting in them and they're gonna kill
us in the middle of the night so you
literally lived on this property
[Music]
no login please
further
[Music]
so someone's at least one person has
definitely died on this property three
that I know one suicide
[Music]
all right
the first person we saw since we got
here has already told us of three deaths
and we know about the dog so we got
squatter's maybe murderers and spirits
possibly we need some like protection
yeah okay
Bing chainsaw or axe owns a little axe
you take your little axe I'll take the
big one
perfect
[Music]
I'm actually genuinely scared right now
it's a little creepy how are we gonna
get in it I just got goose bumps hello
is anybody in there okay see this is
what I don't understand
look at how fresh that is do you see
that that's not a good sign when you
knock on the door maybe someone
I think I brought the wrong tool I need
more like a big fat hammer
I want you to stand with that axe ready
but do not hit me in the head there's
another door okay dude I thought I saw
something
are you serious yeah you saw something
move in there no I thought I saw
something I thought I saw something that
was kidding me oh god it's so gross oh
my god it smells so bad
breathe through your teeth ceiling is
sagging like nuts oh no ghosts no
squatter
but we did find a couple of really good
stoves sorry I swear I just saw facing
that River dude I'm like seeing baby
toys
say stuff like that
we've got some old Timbers of you we can
definitely reuse this
this one has a 6x6 post single you
should come back here though for real
cool cookstove knows life
what happens
[Music]
something weird I think it's just a suck
let's take inventory here no ghosts no
waters of any type lots of wood stoves
and shingles so let's go warm up in the
Airstream breathing walking past the
creepy cabins I don't feel as creeped
out anymore no it's kind of like cool
now all I see are a bunch of resources
things that we can use I think that we
can turn into something cool and pretty
and awesome so we got so much to do to
clear these cabins but we also need to
make the cabin that a beautiful place so
we're gonna finish up the design we're
gonna make a little model we're gonna
find a place for the first cabin to live
but that's all tomorrow right now we're
gonna
[Music]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please